-An Academy Award-nominate
and Emmy-winning actor
and writer you know
as one of the original cas
members of "Saturday Night Live"
and from the movies
"Ghostbusters,"
"The Blues Brothers,"
and so many others.
He has recently added
Crystal Head Onyx,
an agave-based vodka
in a beautiful bottle,
to his award-winning
Crystal Head Vodka line.
Please welcome to the show
the great,
the fantastic Dan Aykroyd.
How are you, Danny?
-Ahh!
A-1, sir!
Good to talk to you.
-And you're outside --
-I am here.
-You're outside with
the Bluesmobile right now.
-I know.
Listen, you know,
I've always looked for these
old Ford Marquises,
the Grand Marquises.
They don't make them anymore
And they ride
like a Rolls-Royce.
They're so overbuilt.
And I was in Upstate New Yor
a couple of years ago, and I -
Middle of the night
in a town up there,
and I just flashed by this town,
and in a car lot, I just saw
a corner of this car.
And I was looking
for a black one.
So I call up, and I find out
that the guy says,
"Oh, well,
I've got two of them."
I said, "Well, I want both."
He said,
"You know your cars, man.
They're FBI cars."
So I get them home,
and dig this, dig this.
Watch this.
-[ Laughs ]
Seth, these --
This car wasn't an FBI car
but it was -- it belonged
to the State Department.
-Wow.
-See that?
You see?
Let me get it right here.
'Cause you really
got to see this here.
How do we get that?
Do you see?
-There you go.
-There it is, there it is.
Look. See?
Department of State,
Washington D.C.
And it has a gun safe in it.
It had a light and siren,
and they were made, you know
for diplomatic assistants,
for couriers,
you know,
take to the airport.
And my fantasy is that
Hillary Clinton
rode in this car.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, you know, I'm going
to lend it to Mike Pompeo.
I've got two of them.
I'm gonna lend them to him
to pack up his family
and head on out any time.
And I'll drive them myself
-That's so kind of you.
-Yeah.
-Now, Dan, what happens when -
-Let's go inside.
-Yeah, let's go inside.
I have to ask, though, Dan
what does a gentleman say
when he's selling two cars
and he realizes Dan Aykroyd'
the one who's buying them?
-Well, I always have
intermediaries, you see?
-Oh, very smart.
-So I don't have to overpay.
Like, I've got -- I have two
of those government cars,
and I have three other
Marquises.
And, Seth,
for all of these cars,
all of them, I'm into them -
I've got five of them.
My daughter has one.
Our neighbor has one.
I've got those two.
My dad used to drive one.
$60,000 for all of them.
-That's fantastic.
-I mean, that's really good.
So, when the name
Aykroyd comes up,
you know, the price will go up
by seven times, so I --
-Right, and I guess you can'
say you're not that Dan Aykroyd.
-No, no.
Yeah, that's hard.
-Hey, I want to say this -
the last time I saw you
was at the "SNL" 40th,
and this year
is the 40th anniversary
of "The Blues Brothers"...
-Yeah.
-...which must be even harde
for you to wrap
your head around.
Is it true that you guys
actually, just one day,
just lost John?
-Well, on the movie --
This is a great story.
We were shooting at the
Harvey, Illinois mall.
You know,
that famous mall scene.
It was an abandoned mall
at the time.
The area had suffered
some economic setbacks.
And we were there
at 3:00 in the morning,
shooting the mall scene,
and lunch had broken,
and we went looking for John
Couldn't find him anywhere
you know?
And so I just --
"What are we going to do?"
So I saw this path
kind of leading out of the -
out of the, you know,
weed-strewn parking lot
into a suburban neighborhood
nearby, and I thought,
"I'll just try that."
And I walked down this path,
and I walked into
the neighborhood, and I looked
All the houses were dark,
but halfway down
one of the streets,
there were lights on.
And I thought,
"Well, I don't know.
I'm gonna --
I've got an instinct here.
I'm gonna try."
And I knocked on the door,
and the guy said, "Yeah?"
And I said, "We're shootin
a movie over here."
"Yeah, I know, I know."
"And we're looking
for one of our actors."
"Yeah, I know -- Belushi.
He came in here
about a half an hour ago,
he raided my fridge.
He's asleep on my couch."
-[ Laughing ]
-He was the guest
who never left.
You know, he'd walk into any -
anybody's house in America
and be welcomed.
You know,
raid the fridge and lay down
It's like Murray,
who goes into these weddings
and goes and -- you know,
they're ambassadors of comedy.
-And it's true.
You know, again, you do it
for that long,
and you do it at a time where,
you know, the show is obviousl
the most iconic thing
on television.
Obviously,
its longevity has spoken
to what you guys established
You and John shared an office.
One day, I would love to wal
the halls of 17 with you,
because I believe it was
an office I ended up with.
But you actually installed -
You made some calls as to what
the 17th floor needed,
including a shower.
And is it true
you put in bunk beds?
-You know, I bet you used that
shower when you were there
I mean,
I established that shower
for the writers staying over
Yes, I put in bunk beds,
and a toaster oven and a kettle.
And, you know, it was --
it was living there.
For me, I lived there --
Like, for most of the show
I lived there
every Tuesday night.
And sometimes
every Wednesday night.
So during the entire run
of "SNL" when I was there.
And, you know, beautiful times
and beautiful memories.
But "The Blues Brothers,"
we still do it.
Jimmy -- John's brother --
and I, still have
The Blues Brothers
Classic Revue.
And we, you know,
in pre-COVID times,
we were going out to casinos
and corporate events
and concert halls and having
really a lot of fun with it.
I do miss the music.
That is something that's
so essential, you know?
And it's too bad
that we can't perform,
all of us in the music industr
or a Broadway performer.
Today, his gig is down.
All my people
at House of Blues,
we have 13 nightclubs.
We have, you know,
several thousand employees
that can't come to work --
barbacks, waiters, waitresses.
This virus is more powerfu
than any CEO
or, you know, head of state.
It's just -- it's a dead zombi
calling the shots.
And I have optimism, though.
I think that mankind,
if we all pull together and ar
sensible about wearing masks
and accepting the vaccines
and don't play into
the ignorance of many
who would deny
what good these things
are gonna do,
we'll get through this.
And I welcome you
to the House of Blues in Vegas
Come and party with us
when we're back up.
-One of the things that can help
people get through
while they're social distancin
is, of course, some spirits.
You've got a new Crystal Skull
Are you excited about having -
And I poured myself a drin
that I'm gonna join you with
But tell us about the new --
the Onyx.
-Well, this has never been -
this has never done before
to take the blue agave plant
which is what
tequila is made out of,
and give it a vodka finish
It's dangerous.
You're gonna like that.
-It's wonderful.
-It has kind of an earthy,
absinthe kind of smell to it
What we've done is
taken the blue agave fluid
mash, and we've mixed it
with the Newfoundland water,
and we have a peppery,
kind of fiery, earthy vodka here
that is based -- and never bee
based on blue agave, a vodka
Never has been.
We're the first to do it.
Here's our Pride
diversity bottle,
which comes out at Pride times
We're very happy that
that constituency follows us
because we're
a Canadian-made vodka
and not a vodka
made in some countries
where gay people are persecuted,
and the consumer in Americ
and Canada and the world
is very conscious
of our identity
as a Canadian product.
Did you have a sip of that
Isn't that nice?
-It's really nice.
It's really -- mm.
It's just what we need.
It's really great.
-Yeah.
You know, some people have sai
it's like a white whiskey
or a kind of a more earthy
sweeter absinthe.
And it's just exactly what -
exactly what we need --
in moderation.
I would take five people to
head, not one person to a head
You know.
-[ Laughs ]
-But in this kind of time
of isolation,
a lot of reflection,
I've been doing
a lot of introspection.
I've been answering
a lot of e-mails.
Seth, you've really
made it in comedy.
You're at the pinnacle,
the peak.
You have your own show,
you have your own --
you can go do stand-up,
you're gonna be producing
other television.
You got to work
with Amy Poehler in "Update.
You guys managed that desk
didn't you?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It was some of the best years
of my life.
-And now it's Jost and Che
and they're doing
such a good job.
-The best.
-It's just wonderful.
It wasn't a gig I enjoyed doing,
but when I saw people
who could really handle it
like you and Amy,
it was wonderful.
-Well, you just -- you sort of
did it as a character.
Isn't that a safe way to say it?
-I did, and I --
And it didn't really fit.
I was trying to be straigh
all the way through
and not accepting the jokes.
You guys had it perfectly,
especially you.
I think probably
you were one of the best eve
to deliver that material.
And you've made it.
And you must have young people
always coming to you and saying,
"How do I get
into the business?"
or, "How do I get
into the industry?"
or, "How do I learn
about comedy?"
Well, I have -- tonight,
I've got some tips for you
-Oh, great.
-For those young people
out there who want to lear
about comedy and improv
and stand-up, the first thin
that you have to do
is you've got to go the
National Comedy Museum
in Erie --
in Jamestown, New York.
It's in the old
Erie Railway Station there
And it takes you right from,
you know, the Greek comedies -
Aristophanes, "The Frogs" --
all the way through
the blue comedy of the '50s.
You know, those blue records
that women and men were making
right through
to "Saturday Night Live"
and "Second City."
It is a museum of comedy
and not to be missed.
And any kid in high school
or college
that wants to be a writer,
a comedy writer, they go there
they're gonna get an afternoon
course in comedy history.
And my motorcycle is there
the motorcycle that I rode
to "SNL" on every four --
each of those four years.
I rode down
the New York Thruway,
taking my life in my hands
on that Harley,
and they came to me and said
"is there any memorabilia we can
get from your time at 'SNL'?
I said, "The bike that kept me
alive for those four years."
-[ Laughs ]
-So that's there,
and the story's there.
The other thing is,
there's an author
called Kliph Nesteroff.
N-E-S-T-E-R-H-O-F-F.
He wrote a book called
"The Comedians."
It's a manual for understandin
British and American comedy,
the influence of Canadians
It's one of the best compendiums
of comedy that I've ever read.
And then Steve Martin's book
"Born Standing Up,"
and his book "The Troubadour."
And then John Lithgow
wrote a book called "Drama."
And so any novice there that
wants to get into the industry
wants to understand rhythm
comedy, performance,
the commitment of an actor
in comedy,
I would say those are the book
to read -- "Born Standing Up,"
"Troubadour," Nesteroff's book
"The Comedian,"
and get to the museum
in Jamestown.
It's there because
Lucille Ball's home was there.
-That's fantastic advice.
So kind of you to pass it along.
Thank you so much
for being here, Dan.
-Oh, absolutely.
-It is always such a pleasure.
Crystal Head Onyx
is available now.